صحفيون يكشف سبب خروج سوناك مسرعا في قمه
المناخ ترامب يهاجم رئيسه مجلس النواب
ويصفها بكلمه بديئه الماسك يحضر حسابات
مشاهير سخروا منهم هذه الاخبار وغيرها
انقلها لكم من قناه العربيه فعلا بكم
في مشهد ان اثار جدلا واسعا وتساؤلات
السوشيال ميديا بعد ظهور رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشي سوناك وهو يخرج مسرعا من
اجتماع في قمه المناخ المنعقده في شرم
الشيخ كشفت صحيفه السر وراء ما حصل صحفيهم
مختص بالشؤون السياسيه
البريطانيه قال انما حدث لم يكن له اي
علاقه
او ان السبب هو قرار تم اتخاذه متاخرا
للقاء ممثلين من المانيا وجنوب افريقيا
مشاركين بالقمه اذ علم سوناك انهم
بانتظاره كما يبدو
في تصريح الاثار الضجه كبيره على مواقع
التواصل وصفات ترامب رئيسه مجلس النواب
نانسي بيلوسي بوصف بدي قائلا انها من
الحيوانات وذلك ضمن مسلسل الانتقادات التي
بينهما وخلال التعليقه على حادثه
ضلع او حديث ضلع بها احد رجال العصابات في
امريكا قال الرئيس الامريكي السابق لقد
ضربه على راسه بعصب اسبوع واطعنه 32
بشكل وحش لقد كان حيوانا مضيفا ان بلوس
قالت ارجوك لا تصفهم بالحيوانات فهم بشر
فقلت لهم حيوانات لاني اعتقد انها من
الحيوانات كذلك
[موسيقى]
الصين هذه المره راحت اعلنت الشرطه اعتقال
سبعه اشخاص في اعقاب اشتباكات بين السكان
والسلطات التي تفرض قيود الحجر الصحي
المرتبطه بفايروس كورونا في شمال شرق
البلاد تقرير افادت بان هذه الاشتباكات
بعد تسجيل جاءت بعد تسجيل السلطات
2230 اصابه جديده بكرونا في مدينه شو
الصناعيه جنوب البلاد فيما اوضح بيان
صحفيه لشرطه مدينه ليلي في مقاطعه شاندونج
انها ستتخذ اجراءات انصار مع حيل الذين
انتهكوا الحقوق القانونيه للحمايه الشخصيه
للمواطنين
[موسيقى]
نزلت ازمه الفنانه المصريه شيرين تتصدر
حديث السوشيال ميديا والجديد هذه المره
وانا محاميها ياسر قنتوش كشف عن تعرضها
للضرب والساحل على يد شقيقها وذلك من خلال
بيان نشره عبر حسابه في فيسبوك انطونش نقل
عن شيرين قولها انها تعرضت لمؤامره كبيره
احد اطرافها شقيقها محمد وبعض المقربين
منها مشيرا الى انها لن تتوانا اللحظه عن
مقادتي اي شخص كان يسيء لها او لي سمعتها
واكد المحامي انها بصحه جيده
وستكشف ما حصل معها بفيديو والاحقا
في خبرينا الاخير حضرت شركه ووتر عددا من
الحسابات الموثقه والتي استبدل اصحابها
اسماءهم ماسك في خطوات تنطوي على السخريه
من مالك المنصه الاجتماعيه الجديد تقارير
افادت بان من بين اصحاب هذه الحسابات
الممثله
التي يتابع صفحتها في تويتر مليونير
مستخدم مشيره الى انها لم تكتفي باستبدال
اسم حسابها بال ماسك بل استبدلت صوره
الحساب الرئيسيه بصوره الملياردات فيما
ورد الاخير قائلا الى الحسابات التي تنتحر
شخصيه
[موسيقى]